Curbing “Impure” Urges, the Birth of the
Graham Cracker
Between 1820 and 1830, America was in the
midst of a health craze.
Sylvester Graham, the creator of the graham
cracker, was on scene with a diet plan he
thought ought to increase physical wellness,
sexual purity, and spiritual health.
The Presbyterian minister from New Jersey
was an avid vegetarian, and on a mission to
rid the world of sexual immorality.
Graham believed wholeheartedly that a vegetarian
diet devoid of spices and sugars, combined
with avoiding foods made with overly processed
flours that often had chemicals added, would
do away with the greatest evil of his day
– lustful thought.
More specifically, he concerned himself with
ridding the world of masturbation, an act
he and others thought led to insanity and
blindness.
First, a little background- Graham spent his
early adult years as a farmhand and teacher.
Later in life, ill health caused him to turn
his attention to ministry work.
His background in harvesting and public address
equipped him to preach about the relationship
between diet and piety, giving birth to the
“Graham Diet”.
Individuals inspired by Sylvester Graham’s
teaching lived in community with one another,
and observed Graham’s strict diet and living
habits, all while working to spread the idea
that diet had a profound effect on righteous
living.
A part of the Graham Diet was what is today
called “graham flour”, which is essentially
a type of non-bleached, “all-natural”
finely ground whole wheat flour.
Among other things made with this flour, Graham
would make what would come to be called “graham
crackers”.
At their inception, graham crackers were incredibly
bland.
The minister preached a high-fiber, whole
wheat diet.
His followers faithfully abstained from meat
and sweeteners, like honey and sugar, and
drank only water.
Graham also consistently reminded his congregation
that consuming food produced by animals led
to impure thoughts and actions, with the exception
of eggs, milk, and cheese which according
to his diet could be consumed, but only if
they were absolutely fresh.
With such diet restrictions, it’s no surprise
that original Graham crackers lacked flavor.
They were not the sweet treat we enjoy today.
The first flour used to make the wafers was
a winter wheat.
The endosperm of the wheat was extracted and
ground into a fine powder.
The bran and germ of the winter wheat was
added to the mixture creating a course type
of flour.
The unrefined flour yielded a naturally nutty
flavor and very slight sweetness.
This supported the crux of Graham’s theory,
that bland food kept one pure in thought and
deed.
Since the days of the Graham Diet, the cracker
recipe has evolved significantly.
For instance, Nabisco began making Graham
crackers with bleached white flour and oils.
The germ is rarely used as excluding the germ
in the flour mixture results in the crackers
having a longer shelf life.
Today, grocery stores carry Graham crackers
of all flavors: sweetened with honey, cinnamon
sugar, and more.
You can even snack on chocolate flavored crackers.
Beyond that, common ways to eat these crackers
include smothering them with peanut butter,
crushing them up for cheese cake and pie crusts,
as well as cloaking them in frosting and decorating
them in gumdrops to replicate winter cottages.
That’s not to mention that they are traditionally
used as the outer layer of a tasty little
marshmallow and chocolate sandwich by campfires
the world over.
If there is indeed a hole in the floor of
heaven, and Sylvester Graham is looking down,
he is surely not happy about any of this.
Of course, neither Graham crackers nor his
diet have ever been shown to even remotely
cure sexual urges, so perhaps he can’t complain
too much.
Sylvester Graham didn’t just give us the
Graham cracker, though.
His influence is believed to have impacted
the direction of other popular branded food
items.
For instance, Dr. John Harvey Kellogg and
his brother, Will, found the minister’s
ideas useful at their Sanitarium in Michigan.
Dr. Kellogg imposed the vegetarian diet on
his patients with the belief that it could
cure some of their troubles.
The brothers even made Graham crackers on
the premises of the ward.
Eventually Will left out some prepared wheat
used to make the facility’s Graham crackers.
When he came back to finish the cooking, the
dough had become hard and stale.
As there wasn’t money to waste a whole batch’s
ingredients, he used it in the baking process
anyway.
Rather than get thin wafers after extruding
the dough through the rollers, he ended up
with hard crispy flakes – somewhat similar
to the corn flakes we eat for breakfast today.
This accident didn’t bode well for the brother’s
relationship.
After the invention of the flakes, which the
people at their Sanitarium enjoyed, Will decided
to market them and felt that adding sugar
would help them sell better.
Needless to say, John found this to be borderline
blasphemous and the two parted ways with Will
founding the now billion dollar Kellogg corporation
(which besides their tasty flakes was soon
to also introduce another breakfast staple,
Rice Krispies), while his brother stuck more
to his original principles and continued to
dedicate his life to ridding the world of
such acts as masturbation.
Graham’s holistic approach to life lives
on.
While his diet did nothing for sexual urges,
today we know that eating lots of fruits and
vegetables, combined with avoiding overly
processed foods, really is good for one’s
health, as is Graham’s suggestion that one
should regularly exercise.
Of course, sticking with bland foods isn’t
at all necessary, but nobody bats a thousand.
Bonus Fact:
• Sylvester Graham also advocated sleeping
on hard mattresses; keeping bedroom windows
open at all times for fresh air (something
Ben Franklin also steadfastly believed in,
much to the chagrin of those who shared lodgings
with him when traveling in winter); cold showers
to invigorate the body; and loose clothing.